halloween season reject nation happy to
have you with us today we are going to
watch a horror short film from alter
that came out a few months ago
called cookie it's been a while since
we've reacted to a horror short film
might have been last october
[Music]
blah blah
a24
hey man if you want instant production
value do an aerial
shot
[Music]
is
yes
you're overdoing the cookies little girl
you're an addict
you're gonna develop you're gonna become
a pre-diabetic
diabetes hey oh my god jessie thank you
so much
yeah of course how was she oh she was
great
so we're still on for saturday a sugar
crash eight o'clock
okay okay thanks again thank you
i was just pretending
what is going on with your face nothing
how many cookies did you eat i only had
one
one that's a lot of crumbs for one
cookie
what's that sound design one
you know i actually counted every cookie
in that cookie jar and if you did only
have one
like i said there should be exactly 13
cookies in that jar you didn't count
them
try me
[Music]
[Applause]
what the hell
this cookie jar is for adults only
anytime that a child has stolen a cookie
from this jar
no more that is
perfect delivery
that says home in the background
anapura presents
that ombre mom's got
[Laughter]
these are adult cookies
vince gilligan presents
filmed by james wong
yes what
the hell
[Applause]
this girl loves her public domain films
that's a neat effect yeah i got some nip
chills
[Music]
damn the little girl hasn't left that
couch all day
all day eating cookies and watching
movies
she has walked this is the furthest
she's walked
[Music]
this is a very real little girl i know
she's great
did you see that shadow i missed it
oh i'm just gonna be doing it with a
clown
dude
oh hell no
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
my nipples are so hard
that clown running shot was really good
yeah that was scary okay
[Music]
he's like a super wide leg all right
well you know where my room is if you
need me and keep that closet door
just really wide open
oh no
oh no
you mustn't leave your room at night
[Music]
oh is it turned yeah i think so
slightly just yeah
[Music]
score by trent resner and atticus ross
yes office space that
[Music]
okay is the tape back together or is it
perfectly put
back together no just the next time she
sees the clown his head's going to be
crushed and cookies will be coming out
[Music]
good old color saturation
[Music]
spooky
bree where's the cookie jar
i don't know you don't know
no bree did you take a cookie jar
hmm nobody likes a liar break
that's why we're the only two people
living in this one
no more cookies in the house then no
more cookies
[Music]
whoa what the hell what the hell is
going on
hey hey how was she
you know she's painting okay well we're
still good for thursday
right uh yeah i'm not sure there's not
sure it's gonna work
in here just fine just yes
hi honey she doesn't seem suspicious
about the babysitter at all
another masterpiece come on
it's way past your bedtime we
perfect
[Music]
oh no oh god oh no
oh no you both reflect the whole house
yes
[Music]
is everything
[Music]
good yeah
i'm just noticing drawing clown face on
everything
oh no the clown's gonna get the mom
[Music]
oh no what the hell
no oh my god no
[Music]
you're gonna have a very noticeable jump
scare
do it at the very last shot oh yeah
that's that's a horror
short uh rule yeah you know you got to
leave us with a jump
damn it's creepy yeah creepy
it seemed to occupy a good amount more
time than i feel like a lot of horror
shorts i've seen
do i thought that was really great
really fun it was really self-aware
i love the trajectory of it i like i
like this idea this riff on the cookie
jar thing we
were combining two elements that idea of
having like
something very childlike and innocent
looking and then i love the approach of
the mom like making something scary
because clearly she's indulging herself
in way too many cookies and that's not
healthy for her that's not good for her
so this might scare her off from doing
it and i love like the
the horror fliparoo of how she like
ultimately embraces the image of the
clown evil cookie thing is she possessed
or is this just some kind of strange
obsession that has you know transmorphed
itself since destroying the jar
well we don't need to know did she
brought the spirit within
yeah i think for a mystery thing you
don't need to know it's like this isn't
the kind of concept
necessarily that i think could be like a
feature film adaptation but in terms of
a
short film this is a really solid one
this is a really great version of it i
think the way it's
shot is wonderful like yeah we might
make our little jokes once in a while
that are like james juan
yeah this looks like something that like
anna
one of those kind of like indie horror
touches to it but it looked
great from beginning to end it's choice
of music
knowing when to be a little bit
tongue-in-cheek or winking at the
audience just to have some fun for that
real
levity humor in the right places that
wasn't as
obvious or obnoxious like there were
some pleasant surprises like the smash
the two weeks later
yeah as opposed to like the next day
because we're expecting like oh that jar
is going to be assembled or something on
the counter the next day so this is a a
clever reveal and twist upon the whole
thing there's just a good amount of the
visual
storytelling in there too i mean they
did have especially the little girl i
thought was super
natural in her performance but also just
seeing the shift in tone from like the
babysitter at first to the babysitter at
the end
yeah like there's a lot of stuff that's
very much in the dialogue but also
just the visuals i thought a were really
beautifully framed
and also b yeah did a nice job of
enhancing the spaces that they were in
especially like in the bedroom it looked
like they used these really wide angles
to enhance
just how long a small bedroom can appear
at night yes
you know from a child's point of view
it's far from the door far from the
closet door it's
it's easy for her to be trapped in there
yeah exactly and even though the
flashlight bits like this
managed and this is kind of a longer
short than some of the ones that come
out on the internet you know it's more
than four minutes anyway but this seemed
to have a good amount of
pace to it and and dynamics because like
i like that montage at night where she's
going around the house with the
flashlight
segwaying into it she goes out into the
street and smashes the cookie jar
the beginning and the end we're kind of
you know what i what i was imagining
from a clown-based horror short but
there was so much in the middle that
made it feel a little more lived in that
i was
anticipating it yeah well they have this
concept of the clown
slowly coming to life whether that be
something she's manifesting in her own
mind through her own childlike
imagination because i mean it's
established that first sequence with
like the red drapery over
like pulling that off like it was a good
great effect and then the clown sneaking
up on her was clearly a part of her
nightmare i'd imagine this is all just
part of her mind but i love how it's
like slowly consuming her and slowly
manifesting itself into her
reality because it's captured from the
little girl's perspective because first
you have the clown cookie jar
then after smashing it to beds then it's
all coming to life with the paintings
then planting it onto people then to the
very last image where
she now sleeps with it and it's and it's
a full-on like
human body clown at least in her own
mind at that moment right
so i love that it's slowly coming to
life and this little girl is wonderful
like that's a
she feels like a horrible children in
horror
are often the things that can really go
wrong they can either seem way too
mature or they can seem like
this doesn't even sound like a kid in
terms of like too childish this seemed
like a real girl you know yeah
and because she seemed so earnest i
couldn't tell if it was gonna end up
such that she's the ghoulish thing by
the end or if she's gonna be the victim
of the thing by the end and i think that
plays the sort of psychological angle
quite nicely too
yeah cause i like the thematic approach
of how
you know that silly conversation of like
horror movies don't let kids watch them
or something because
they're going to turn them into killers
you know like that that kind of
weird argument that people form the
things this is what makes people
monsters kind of
having fun with that like she's obsessed
with horror movies you're seeing her
watch these classic horror films at the
beginning
and she's obsessed with them and she's
repeating out the lines
like she's very much involved with it
and then yeah this is all going into her
psychosis
of consuming her so i think there's
actually some wonderful metaphors to
hear you know the stuff with the mom was
it was cool yeah i think i did find it
amusing that she gives her such a harsh
caveat for the clown cookie jar because
you could also argue that like that
probably had some kind of psychological
effect on her
yeah if you go on this guitar you're
gonna die well there was something that
felt like weirdly detached about the mom
and i can't quite pick up on the choice
about it that's a terrible parenting
choice to give such a terrifying clown
thing but then also with all the clown
makeup and everything going on and the
fact that babysitter was so scared that
there was no
maybe there was a scene that was cut or
or a reaction or a look to the way the
babysitter was behaving
but there's something that feels
emotionally
out of the situation not fully connected
here that
one part of me kind of likes the ominous
mysterious angle of that the other part
is i can't really tell what they're
going for
because because she doesn't acknowledge
the babysitter she doesn't she's like
hey are you okay you cool
even though like well look at all these
crazy clown doll things and she
she obviously got rid of the cookie jar
you know so like are you sure your
daughter's not [ __ ] disturbed from
your actions
yeah yeah yeah and i do i think there is
a dual effect of that because part of it
was enhancing the fact that the girl
really does feel like an island in this
i mean there are only three other
characters if you count the clown and so
like they all feel kind of outside of
her little realm and so in that way i
bought it but yeah there were times
where i was like are you supposed to be
a totally normal mom
or a suspicious mom yeah and some of
that comes out of the tone as well
because i thought the
like the actress did a fine job yeah it
was cool to see that this clown thing
also doesn't become
in a way of this monster murdering
people or her becoming a killer
she just has like an eerie uncomfortable
effect on the babysitter primarily and
yeah and if anything it's this weird
loves like the
you know children who have imaginary
friends yeah and it's her version of it
she loves horror
and then her imaginary friend manifests
into this
horrific clown but it's not doing
anything yeah yeah
yeah and then it yeah it becomes almost
like she's taking the horror out of it
by making it her imaginary buddy because
she's so afraid of it at first and it
does represent almost like a little
character arc in there because she
confronts the thing
and then you know destroys it and then
from there she's uh
after a while not that afraid of it any
longer you know what she could have done
is just put the cookie jar in a higher
cap
yeah that's true but knowing this little
girl she was like
a ladder and caught up there she's a
cookie junkie she's just
she's an addict yeah this is called
cookie monster
but this was great i thought music was
awesome too everything about
on a technical scale was perfect and uh
the acting from the little girl was cool
and i loved the way they handled this
especially for clown horse clown horror
not possessed doll or possessed toy but
instead of that it's a cookie jar
so like they it could have easily fallen
into nothing but cliches but they
managed to
steer in different directions and toy
with when you think it's going to be a
cliche like when she's coming down the
stairs after smashing the cookie jar
it's going to be one it's going to be
there but it's not it's two weeks later
so i i love
that but i love that line too why would
you bring that home
yeah perfect line yeah and for the kid
in one of these to be like that is
clearly a creepy albeit childish thing
like it's
that was very nice and refreshing
because you see so many horror movie
kids
who are sidled up to their creepy toy
and then that makes the ending punch
better yeah
yeah it's not like she already has a
creepy doll she gets the real thing and
befriends it
so while i would have liked a little bit
more clarity on the mom
choice the way they handled her i'd say
like still effect
98 i would give yeah yeah still well
effective
all right guys what do you think of this
horror short film cookie make sure to
subscribe to alter when you get the
chance
recommend some other horror short films
to check out too subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell
last but not least
i would like to shout out a woman named
rosa parra
rosa while you've been killing it on the
interwebs
with all these film review outlets
you've been going through
let's not forget you are a mother a
mother with children who probably
love cookies so rosa while you get so
focused on your daytime job and your
passionate
outlets that you're doing and pursuing
which i'm sure will
bring in a great source of income one
day make sure
your children are not
secretly plotting to murder you yeah
that's what i was trying to get at by
tying it in with cookies
clowns i don't know where you got that
make sure they do not
get knives and try to stab you okay
mm-hmm john i'm trying to rip off the
dough
sure they don't okay i get it all right
so make sure you don't put a plastic bag
over your thrower and cook that with it
you know while you're a sleeper exactly
see now you're getting the joke now
you're getting the job they don't turn
into a wear tied into cookie
yeah and i don't know what this whole
thing about clown is and stuff but
make sure that they did not strangle you
with a metal wire
yeah definitely not a metal wire make
sure they don't like close your head
into a piano or anything like that or
drop an anvil on you
yes but always leave out some cookies
for them in a cookie jar because you
know
if sometimes it's hard to give them the
undivided detention they sometimes feel
like they want
so fill that void with sweets sweets
blood sugar raise it through the roof
and maybe
befriend a clown love you rosa